oh my dog escaped and I smell it's heard
on the floor somewhere you might see a
couple clips where you're like okay
why are they talking to his dog like
that that's because you're not a [ __ ]
dog owner there's a little turn right
there I'm gonna kill this gun I picture
she ran upstairs out of fear I love my
dog mind you but just like how people
say dogs are a part of your family
family fight some time and if your
family member took a squat and [ __ ] in
front of your door in the dining area
and in that breakfast nook and then on
your life how would you feel the booty
escaped yes I clean up all the food I
thought a fellow no there's one over
just pooped em you think when I came
back and there was a turn at the
doorstep and then P I can I hate you so
much
what is wrong with you Sam what's wrong
with you for what purpose do you walk
around this house cool all the way
downstairs [ __ ] in front of the door
[ __ ] no don't shake there's no point you
end up here you are not that smart I
[ __ ] hate you
you understand that I'm gonna give you
up for some nice white people it made me
so mad
and you know what it's partially my
fault too because it's just
entertainment understand when I'm angry
half the time so literally the whole
time I'm yelling at her and she's
wagging her tail it's cuz she's so happy
to see me that's how innocent and
beautiful puppies are but I also can't
get mad at her because she's just being
a puppy
you know puppies don't know what they're
doing dogs are supposed to [ __ ] whatever
the [ __ ] they want and I'm mad at my dog
for being a dog but it would start
making me more angry because she didn't
realize I was angry
I don't know today I kind of had an idea
of what I wanted to do yeah I don't want
to get it super
get complicated
every time somebody these are rules she
thinks that they're leaving her forever
but they're never coming back idiot
not so dumb I've owned four dogs my
whole life I never had a dog as dumb as
this one they usually get like oh you're
leaving you're gonna come back I
understand I've had a lot of dogs in my
past and it's yeah I always say the same
thing when I get mad I'm like you're so
dumb all my other dogs would never like
you yes they were they were exactly like
her it's just is that that growing pain
of having a puppy and kind of training
the puppy that's very difficult I love
the little [ __ ] got abandonment issues
like I've been abandoned I'm a poop
everywhere I know that's what I was
reading - like they poo like little dots
every time why don't you just put in one
solid spot is cuz they'll pee and poo
everywhere so you'll find its scent cuz
it's afraid that they got abandoned I'm
like we've been doing this for four
months now I've caught came back a lot
don't you think you would understand by
now you [ __ ] jackass never ever get a
dog people ever if you are going to get
a dog because you think it's going to be
easy it's not it's an investment it's
going to be a whatever 8 to 14 to 16
year vestment that you were going to
keep with your life everybody thinks
that having a dog is like the most
amazing home with the best companions on
earth do you realize that you have to
feed and clean up it [ __ ] every [ __ ]
day there's not a day as a child that
never grows up always it's like having a
30 year old it's like having a 40 no kid
that still uses diapers or not diapers
at all poops on the foot
exactly and nowadays - because there's
so much like videos and like people that
don't like hitting their dogs you can't
even hit your dog like an aging parent
you got to be nice to Enosh it's [ __ ]
weird
I actually don't beat my dog I think I
hit her once I feel so [ __ ] guilty
I do this thing where I come up to and I
go no no and I smack her in the nose
with one finger like this
it's you're over-exaggerating ass [ __ ]
you lucky I'm not treating you like a
little Asian baby I went like this to my
kid there's a white person in the clock
oh my god what are you doing
like I'm swatting a fly around his face
just happened to be honest no disciples